un apretón de manos polémico el
presidente francés Emmanuel macron
recibió este viernes en París al
príncipe heredero Saudita muham salman
es la Segunda visita del príncipe a la
capital francesa en menos de un año un
viaje condenado por muchos incluida
amnistía internacional que ha denunciado
el papel de Francia en la rehabilitación
de la imagen de salman especialmente en
relación con el asesinato en 2018 del
periodista
al príncipe heredero de haberlo ordenado
podemos ver ahora que vin salman está en
una ofensiva diplomática y finalmente
los países están empezando a olvidar un
poco lo que sucedió en ese Embajada de
Turquía y están extendiendo la alfombra
roja para este asesino no hay otra
palabra para ello pero según Francia el
viaje es vital como muchos asuntos
internacionales ineludibles en la agenda
un comunicado publicado por el palacio
del Elíseo reveló una amplia gama de
temas tratados entre las dos partes
incluida la guerra en Ucrania macron
espera convencer al también Primer
Ministro Saudita para que presiona
Vladimir Putin a terminar el conflicto
otros temas es de la agenda fueron Irán
y la inestabilidad política en Líbano la
energía También estuvo en el centro de
las discusiones la estancia de Bin
salman en Francia parece que será larga
el príncipe heredero asistirá a los días
22 y 23 de junio a la Cumbre de París
sobre un nuevo pacto mundial de
financiación organizada por macron